one of the biggest things for me was
just seeing myself in the show and then
knowing how I am now and seeing such a
difference I mean I'm fundamentally the
same person but having been married to
Lauren now for a year and a half you
know I think I've kind of absorbed some
of her in a way some of her person some
of her personality and and for good
reason because you know I love her and I
admire her and so I think your partner
when they can make you better you know
that's a beautiful thing Lauren and
Cameron today you guys have definitely
proved that love is life you may now
call yourself those terrorist names of
husband and wife sorry no but honestly
it's been an adventure I believe that
it's kind of like we did it backwards
right it's like we got married and then
we kind of started dating after the
marriage so I feel like each day we're
just learning more and more about each
other I mean our relationship is
flourishing of course it hasn't been
without stumbles and trials and
tribulations like any relationship I
mean we've really had to learn each
other I mean I went from being a hermit
I mean it's the truth to like living
with someone 24/7 and raising a little
fur baby dog you know so I mean those
are adjustments that we really had to
make and just kind of grow into each
other and blend families and travel to
Maine and you know camera needs to come
to d'être but I mean it's been a
wonderful adventure every day is
something new I do
fill up that ad for you so strong it's
overwhelming sometimes
in with you makes me feel thankful that
day I just felt this sense of calm of
course deep down I was nervous in some
way I think like any groom would
probably be but I just kept thinking
about Lauren and reminding myself that I
needed to trust her and I knew that she
loved me and so I felt a sense of calm
the whole day and then the moment I saw
her walking down the aisle I lost all
composure and it was it was a reverse
for me like I was a nervous wreck like
walking around crying sporadically like
with my family and something about when
it was time to like walk down the aisle
like I was just like let's do it like
cool I knew that it was what I wanted to
do I was happy I saw camera and I saw
how emotional he was getting and it was
just reassuring slike this is love this
man loves me and I love him just as much
and you know I was excited to really
take that step and start this next phase
of our life before the wedding I kind of
took a day and I just really kind of did
almost like a pros and cons almost and I
was just like you know this is the
happiest that I've ever been in my life
and I feel like so many of the girls
we've all been saying this whole
self-sabotage thing but it's so true and
honest it's like I've never been so
happy to the point where I was afraid of
the disappointment that could possibly
come from allowing myself to let go and
be that happy so I just kind of had to
be like boring like why are you stopping
your own happiness because you're afraid
to be happy like that doesn't make any
sense like so I had to silence all those
things and just really let myself go and
let myself be loved properly a key word
cuz I never had that and it scared me
and I was like I'm not doing that
anymore like this is it I'm running
towards the light not being able to like
meet all of the family and and best
friends and spend time with them before
getting married because that's not
something that was important to me they
didn't really show that but that's one
of the reasons why I was kind of like
man we're skipping all these steps that
I really want to do so yeah that was
hard yeah that's true there were
skeptics skips for sure you know
conventional wedding
ceremonies that we wish we could have
done but the other element was although
we learned each other very deeply in
such a short amount of time there were
still things that we needed to learn and
I think for any married couple or even
any relationship you're constantly
learning about your partner if you're
doing it right so we and every day we're
still learning more about each other I
know that my dad is concerned and I
definitely value his opinion this is Kim
this is me okay
hmm I got a million questions I mean I
love Lawrence that he's an amazing guy
very sweet guy you know he comes over a
lot for dinner and you know I'm just
thankful now that we have such a strong
family together and that's you know of
course Lauren's a lot like her father so
it's natural that I'm gonna love him too
oh he's like crazy over Cameron like
it's crazy he's that's his son you know
L know in your eggs are drying up Oh
finally I'm not getting any younger
first time as you heard my mom told me
my eggs are shriveling up that's a real
thing so I was serious about her
grandkid but not even just based on her
between us who say like another year
I mean baby I mean my paternal instincts
pretty hard are like fur baby we're
already like oh my god this is what its
gonna be like he's still a puppy so it's
like literally our kid we had to like
house-trained up so we like this is like
potty training he was teething and we're
just like yeah I feel like so many
people have been inspired by our story
like I would love to continue it and you
know there's so much more of us to be
shared you know we're just starting our
journey like this is just the beginning
yeah we've been touched by so many fans
reaching out and just asking hey are we
gonna see you guys you know do spin-off
or something else and we would love to
[Music]